dog is in Tulsa Oklahoma hi Doug how are
you hello Dave
I'm finishing Financial Peace University
next week and I'm very grateful for your
work thank you sir okay I'm calling
about a ten year old debt this is an
auto repossession from 2008 they is our
last commercial debt I owe about $3,000
on it mm-hmm
I don't contest' its validity mm-hmm
however it's ten years old I've been
receiving some counsel by some friends
who I don't know if they know what
they're talking about or not but I don't
know I'm not legally or morally
responsible to pay that debt to a debt
agency that bought the debt mm-hmm and
you know what I'd rather talk to you
okay well there may be a statute of
limitations that is run in your state to
where you're not technically legal but I
gotta tell ya it's gonna be a thorn in
your side and they're going to be a
problem in your life until you clean
this up morally they lost money on a car
you promised to pay for that you didn't
pay for
so I disagree morally you do owe some
money now the question is what and what
is reasonable and what is reasonable in
your situation okay number one have you
talked to them yes okay what are they
I've already paid a thousand to the
original but $4,000 you've already given
up a thousand you've already given them
a thousand that's correct when within
the past 45 days okay all right so the
accounts active again now and so and are
you able to just write a check and pay
the three no okay
all right well I mean it is very
reasonable to make them an offer and say
I don't have three I have one and if
you'll settle this three for another one
we got a deal if you don't then I'm not
giving you any money right now until I
have some more money okay
and so to settle it for less than the
full amount given that you don't have
any money if they chose to accept that
there's nothing wrong with that now if
you call me up you say got $100,000 in
the bank
and I owe $4,000 on this I'd say try to
check your the money but when you don't
have the money there's nothing wrong
with offering them a settlement for
money you do have then if they take that
then that was their choice so you've not
ripped somebody off they've made a
decision you know I have a company that
owes me $40,000 that has not paid me for
15 years I will never see them $40,000
if they call me up out of the blue and
offered me $4,000 for that 40 I would
take it in a heartbeat because I just
figured that's a bird in the hand and I
am never even gonna see this bush I mean
seriously you know these people are
never gonna pay me it's gone and I'm not
bitter about it or anything I just think
about every morning but not saying so
you know that so that that would be on
my part though if I said no you still
owe the money you know because you owe
me
you know then you still owe the money
morally you follow me so if you want to
make them an offer and they don't take
it that's fine yes I don't have $3,000
right now and I'm not sending your
payments I'm gonna save up money and
make you an offer and if you don't take
that I'm gonna make you another offer
and if you don't take that someday maybe
I can pay you but I just if you want the
money right now we can we can wrap up
the account for a thousand bucks have
you scraped together thousand bucks and
settle that get it in writing be sure
you get whatever you do with this
company on this hold of debt in writing
so that when it's settled it it or when
it's paid it's gone forever you don't
want them coming back even if you pay
the whole four thousand and say later oh
we forgot about the fees there's another
seven thousand dollars in fees we forgot
to tell you you know no you need in
writing that this wraps up the account
concludes our business this is the Dave
Ramsey show